the best qualifying Juniors and seniors
from across the country flock to the
capital of Jess and America for the 2023
U.S Juniors and Senior championships in
St Louis players spanning Generations
came together to compete for a national
title in the Gateway City
thirteen-year-old Phenom Alice Lee
showed that she is no longer a rising
star or the future of American chess the
future is here and she is shining bright
playing incredible throughout the event
going undefeated with an impressive
seven and a half out of nine years old
to win her first ever National Title the
Juniors was a topsy-turvy event from
start to finish with multiple players in
contention for the title going into the
final round but the world's youngest
Grandmaster abimanyu Mishra was on a
mission stating early on that his goal
was to win it all and he proved that it
was absolutely possible drawing his
final round game to win the event
outright and become the 2023 uh us
Junior Champion everyone loves a good
Redemption story and this year's author
was Mele catchian the tail Ender and
last year's senior Championship came
back better than ever having the
tournament of his life to go from worst
to First and win the 2023 U.S Senior
Championship three new national
champions have been crowned will their
Reigns be long or will Challengers rise
up to Dethrone them find out next year
when the nation's best return to St
Louis for the 2024 U.S Juniors and
Senior championships